Hi there space cadets, Jules here for a
DNews Short.
Today, the space community is abuzz with news
that… we’ve found organic
material on the dwarf planet Ceres!
Researchers working with NASA say, quote,
“Ceres contains key ingredients for life.”
So there's a chance basic life could or did
exist on this dwarf planet.
To catch you up, Ceres is the largest object
in the asteroid belt between Mars and Jupiter.
We’ve been studying it for a while, but
new research published today in Science Magazine
revealed that NASA’s Dawn spacecraft has
confirmed the existence of concentrated organic
molecules on Ceres’ surface.
And the craziest thing?
These materials likely came from inside the
dwarf planet.
So, to back up, organic molecules are any
chemical molecule that contains carbon, and
are the building blocks of all known life.
We already knew Ceres had water ice and hydrated
ammonia, meaning ammonia mixed with water.
But this is whole new discovery.
An unusually high concentration of organic
matter in the northern hemisphere of Ceres
was detected with NASA’s spectrometer – an
instrument that maps visible and infrared
light.
We can’t tell the exact makeup of the materials
right now, but researchers say they match,
quote, “tar-like minerals such as kerite
or asphaltite.”
So, how do they know that these materials
originated on Ceres and didn’t come from,
say, an asteroid or comet impact?
Well, the areas where they found the organic
materials also contain other substances that
are endogenous, meaning that they came from
inside the dwarf planet.
So it is likely that the organics also originated
on Ceres.
In addition, if the materials were carried
on an asteroid, the heat from the collision
would have probably destroyed them.
This discovery adds yet another piece of evidence
that organics exist throughout our solar system,
and it could help us learn more about the
evolution and distribution of organic species.
Plus, at 4.5 billion-years-old, Ceres has
been around since nearly the beginning of
our solar system.
If these organic compounds were also around
that early, that may have provided a lot more
time for life to form outside our planet.
There’s no evidence of other life yet, but
this is still a pretty exciting breakthrough.
Want to know more about Ceres?
Check out our video about how it might have
volcanoes that spew ice here.
What do you think about this discovery?
Does it blow your mind?
Tell us!